-Thank you so much for tuning in
to "The Tonight Show."
Let's get to the news and jokes.
Well, guys, earlier today,
President Trump called in
to "Fox and Friends" and
announced that he's gonna start
coming on the show once a week.
But I think he caught
the hosts by surprise.
Watch this.
-I haven't heard that.
-Yeah, Trump announced
that he'll be joining
"Fox and Friends" once a week,
so at least
he's cutting back a bit.
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
It'll only be one call a week
and 168 hours per call.
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, wow, it's Monday again.
I got to go.
My --"
[ Laughter ]
I'm not surprised
Fox had to schedule
a weekly call with Trump.
He's like your relative who
always calls at the worst time.
"Oh, you're in the shower?
Oh, that's interesting.
I was taking a shower
the other day, and I --"
[ Laughter ]
After the surprise announcement,
Trump was asked about
Bob Woodward and his new book,
and here's what he had to say.
[ Laughter ]
"It was very boring.
None of the pictures popped up,
and nothing I scratched
made a smell."
[ Laughter ]
Yep, Trump claims he read
a 480-page book in one night.
Please, I have more faith
in there being a real vaccine
before the election.
[ Laughter ]
I get the feeling Trump read the
front cover and the back cover
and thinks that means
he read the entire book.
"I read it cover to cover."
[ Laughter ]
The only way Trump
finished a book in one night
is if he ate it.
[ Laughter ]
"Very bland, very boring."
With the first presidential
debate just two weeks away,
Trump was asked
how he's preparing for it.
Here's what he had to say.
-So, no, he's not
preparing for the debate.
[ Laughter ]
Later, Trump was asked about
his repeated suggestion
that Joe Biden is taking drugs.
Listen to this.
-You think he's taking some
sort of drugs to pep him up?
-Hmm. Interesting.
Now, remind me,
which candidate had a chunk
of white stuff
fly out of their nose last week?
[ Laughter ]
-Ugh!
-"That's right.
We're gonna make [sniffs]
America [sniffs] great [sniffs]
again, again.
[Sniffs]
Eventually,
they wrapped things up,
and Trump was eager to confirm
next week's call,
but I'm not sure all the hosts
were on the same page.
Watch this.
-Then we'll do it every week?
We're gonna do it every week?
-All right.
-Sounds good.
-Mr. President,
thank you very much.
You may want
to do it every week,
but Fox
is not committed to that.
We're gonna take it
on a case-by-case basis,
and Joe Biden, as well,
is always welcome to join us
for 47 minutes, like we just did
with the President.
[ Laughter ]
-You know it's been a great chat
when the person
you're talking to
says exactly
how many minutes it's been.
[ Laughter ]
"Well, we've been talking
for 47 minutes, Grandma."
[ Laughter ]
Well, guys, everyone's
talking about this today.
Apple held
their big annual event
and unveiled new versions
of the iPad and iPad Air.
Check it out.
Yep, the iPad Air has
an all-new A14 bionic chip.
It's really powerful.
To give you an idea,
it's the same chip
that's powering Mark Zuckerberg.
[ Laughter ]
And this is great --
the new iPad's screen
is now sharper than ever before.
That's right.
Experts say it'll revolutionize
the way you watch TikToks
on the toilet.
[ Laughter ]
Apple also introduced
a new Apple Watch.
Take a look at this.
Joe Biden was like, "Damn, if
only the numbers were bigger."
[ Laughter ]
Yep, the Apple Watch is supposed
to make everything super easy
while you're on the go,
or as Americans in 2020 put it,
"On the what now?"
Apple also announced that
they're gonna start offering
their own fitness classes.
People were like,
"Yeah, yeah great.
Can I still order Domino's
with my watch?"
[ Laughter ]
This is interesting.
I saw that Pepsi is launching
a new kind of beverage.
Check this out.
-Pepsi unveiling its new drink,
called DriftWell,
with ingredients said to promote
relaxation and ease stress.
-Yeah.
That sounds way better
than what I've been doing --
pouring Nyquil
into my SodaStream.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, the name of the drink
is DriftWell.
DriftWell doesn't sound
like a drink.
It sounds like
a retirement community
where some bad stuff went down.
[ Laughter ]
I think
I've seen that "Dateline."
And finally, speaking of drinks,
Red Lobster is launching
a new Mountain Dew cocktail,
called Dew-garita.
Here it is.
Yeah.
I don't know.
The Dew-garita sounds like
something you drink
before a colonoscopy.
[ Laughter ]
Fun fact -- if you dunk your
Cheddar Bay biscuit
in your Dew-garita,
you legally become governor
of West Virginia.